[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author of the book paycheck to purpose
and host of the Ken Coleman show is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
as a reminder Ken show is all about
career and all about job and all about
finding work that you're passionate
about good about and creative about yeah
so he can help you with all that too
while we're here again phone number
88255 225 James starts this hour in
Canada hi James how are
you I'm doing very well better than I
deserve how are you Dave better than I
deserve sir what's
up this is an honor to talk to you you I
am such a fan of the show well I'm
honored to talk to you how can we
help uh just I just have a quick well
not a quick question now me and my wife
are are planning to get out of debt as
soon as possible and I just have a
question that's been lingering on my
mind I have uh some Investments about
$5,000 Canadian in uh some
ETFs and I'm just wondering if I should
sell my investments to pay off debt okay
what kind of debt have you got
I have a line of credit that's about
$199,000 uh we also have some credit
card debt and uh and a car loan as well
how much do you ow how much do you owe
on your credit
cards uh my credit card itself is about
$113,000 okay so there's a there's an
old rule that I've learned I've Twisted
it around a little bit and used the rule
because it's a
decision-making uh framework that that's
helped me a bunch it comes from the
Harvard investment
newsletter and um the guy in there says
when you've made a bad when you made an
investment and let's say you bought a
stock at $100 a share and it went down
to $75 a share okay and so you're about
to lose you know you're going to lose
money if you sell it while it's down but
you really don't think it's ever going
to come up it's it's not it's a crummy
company it's probably going to go on
down but you're waiting on it to at
least come back to where what you paid
for it his point is what you paid for it
doesn't matter all that matters is the
future of the stock from
$75 what's it going to do go up or down
and his what he says is don't analyze it
based on what you paid for it that's
called a sunk cost analysis now I'm
that's an investment process now I'm I
flip that and I use it in situations
like yours or other situations like I'm
in as well
sometimes if you own something and you
reverse engineer it it tells you what
you should do instantly let me give it
to you in this way let's pretend you
didn't have $113,000 in credit card debt
but you had $8,000 in credit card debt
would you and you did not have a $5,000
ETF would you go buy an borrow an
additional 5,000 on your credit cards to
invest into an ETF well crud
no no no I mean we can answer that
instantly can't we that sounds stupid
when you say it that way doesn't it but
all that is is the reverse of your
question so if you would not borrow
5,000 more on your credit cards in order
to buy an ETF we would instantly cash
out the ETF to pay 5,000 down on the
credit cards because it's the same
difference just
backwards yeah that's you know what when
you say it like that it's very very
obvious it's kind of like sometimes we
get we get we get paralyzed by these
decision makings because we're stuck in
the moment moment rather than in the
reverse you can do it with a boat if you
got a boat sitting in the driveway
that's worth $10,000 you go if I had
$10,000 in the middle of my kitchen
table would I go buy a boat just like
that if I didn't have that boat well
crud no we had used the thing in five
years I'm tired of it takes up space I'm
paying insurance on it I it's it's it's
going down in value or we use it every
weekend the kids love that boat of
course I would go buy that boat if I had
$110,000 and I didn't have that boat
well then you keep the boat then but if
you go well no I would never buy that
boat again then it's way past time to
sell that boat right you you just
reverse engineer and it tells you what
to do in these situations Ken does it
with a job don't you I mean you could go
and go I hate my job boy if you didn't
have this job today would you take this
job Lord no then why are you still
working there you know true yeah yeah
people say should I stay or should I go
and I said well uh just the fact that
you're answering the question yeah we
need to go yeah you wouldn't stay if if
I had a job waiting for you today so
that's absolutely right it's a great
great analogy yeah so that that's how
I'm going to tell you um and and but
more importantly is the why or how the
process we use to make the decision
James it tells us instantly with a
little bit of reverse engineering now uh
um you know that's why we tell people
not to take money out of a retirement
plan because there's a big penalty and a
big tax in order to put the money into
your credit card it's going to hit you
in the states it would hit you about 40%
between penalties and taxes so that's
like saying Dave would I borrow 40%
borrow money at 40% interest to pay down
on my debt well crap no that's dumb
we're not doing that and so same that
that that's why we tell you not to cash
out return but yes to cash out the ETF
yeah makes a lot of sense and in this
case huge momentum coming out of this
decision as well you know you know I
think Ken the the great resignation that
we just came through after the fouchy
pandemic everybody quit their job
because they wanted to have a better
life yeah um was caused a little bit by
that but even the great regret by people
wishing they didn't quit their jobs uh
is also caused by that isn't it it's all
this it's all this it was more emotion
driven impulse driven than it was
thinking okay I don't want to live this
way that's exactly right well we're
trying to get the Quick Fix and the
Quick Fix was I'm going to leave a
company where I'm valued and I actually
enjoy the work and I'm going to go over
here for a 15% raise then they got there
and it wasn't what they thought and the
Rays wore off the high you know there's
a decision like o I make a decision and
I get ahead quick you feel like you've
gained the system then they're there for
three months this place sucks and that's
what you call the great regret and by
the way what Dave talked about folks is
we're talking about millions of workers
millions millions who said I wish I had
stayed at my previous company this is
not like a little Trend this was a major
wave of people and again we were trying
to game the system and get the Quick Fix
and you realize oh I would have been
better off staying where I am am I'd be
happier more fulfilled and that affects
my my anxiety depression which affects
my sleep my physical life my
relationship life with my wife my kids
if I'm dragging all that crap from work
home with me uh and I didn't get that
much of a behavior change and to this
point if you took a 15% raise to try to
pay off credit card debt or to pay off
well I can live more and you just kept
spending and by the way Dave that's what
we've seen right now in our economy we
just got the latest reports out the GDP
is up because the consumer in America
are spending like Congress and credit
card debt is going up with it and we've
got to take control of our spending take
control of our habits and getting out of
debt back to this call uh and not just
chasing the next big thing it's the
discipline to say I'm going to change my
life change the way I act and those are
going to guide my decisions not the next
big Quick Fix to feel like I just gain
the system got to change who you are
more money to get in a worse place
wears off in about 20 minutes really
fast yeah you get a career hangover from
that one yeah and then you try to drown
it out with credit card
debt ouch funny how not James James is
going to pay down his credit J with an
ETF this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
Deb settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple 8825 5225
Jaden is in Portland Oregon hi Jaden how
are
you pretty good Dave how you doing
better than I deserve what's
up so my income has drastically
increased in this last year and I'm
trying to find out if I should buy a
house soon with three and a half% down
or if I should wait and put down the
20% okay tell me your story what's
happening um so well I was just working
regular jobs U not making too much money
year and then I got offered a job where
now I make 120 Grand a year I'm only 19
years old um I was living in my van this
job I do have housing um but I have a
fiance at home who's still living in the
van with our pups
so that's why I'm kind of trying to
figure out if I should put down three
and a half percent get her out of the
van or if I should wait and put down
20% okay so you go from a van to housing
is furnished but they won't let your
fiance stay
there um no because um I I kind of I
can't talk about what I do too much but
I just work with individuals um that uh
just need some extra help so I'm away
from home for two weeks at a time so I'm
with another person in the room and they
can't come along with
me I see
okay
um why is renting not an option in this
you've given us two extremes I feel like
going from a van to buying your first
house congratulations on the income but
why is renting on your own not a part of
this
equation um the renting is only out of
the equation because um where I live
rent is uh very high I understand make a
lot of money um but I really like saving
my money I've been watching you for a
while and spending money I just it just
makes me not feel good and I have a big
dog and with the big dog a lot of places
won't let me in so then I'd be looking
at paying like two grand Plus for
housing and uh that I'm just kind of not
really too fond of we've been living in
the van now for almost two years so
we're kind of comfortable in it so she
would be all right waiting until 20%
you're comfortable in the van with a
giant
dog yeah well it's like an RV van so
it's a van but it's an RV so it's all
fitted out like an RV and we're outside
people usually we're outside um J and
the puppy like the dog he's pretty good
in the van yeah Jaden um when Sharon and
I got married um I refused to move into
an apartment because I had two big dogs
that I loved and um one was half Mal
mute and the other one was um a
um fire dog what uh Dal Dalmation the
Dalmation didn't like animals and I mean
didn't like people and the Mal mute
didn't like animals so uh I was a
22-year-old genius and I moved into a
rental property uh instead of moving
into an apartment uh the first week the
dalmatian bit a jogger and the Mal mute
ate the neighbor's
cat and uh so I decided I was not going
to be able to keep my large dogs that I
love because they were going to cause me
to lose everything I owned even though I
love dogs more than just about most
humans but I had to give away those dogs
um and I had rented a property a
particular property nothing to do with
my wife's needs or my needs but the
needs of the dogs and they didn't make
it 3
weeks um I tell you that story to say um
sir I'm an old man and so I'm going to
give you old man advice don't make
decisions about where you live based on
a dog ever don't make decisions about
where you make your fiance live live in
a van
ever and um if your she's your fiance
let's set a date get married and go rent
an apartment and or go find a place in
the country and rent it for the big dog
only to discover three weeks later that
he ran off to
Tennessee and now you've got a place
Dave's house so he's came he come to my
house that's where he ended up he's what
that what was that movie uh Homeward
Bound home bound he'll be Homeward Bound
to Tennessee and hang out with Uncle
Dave but um yeah so uh
I'm just telling this is actual true
story I actually did this dumb butt
stuff Jaden and so uh this was so long
ago we've we've been married 42 years
and so there were actually newspapers in
those days and they had these things in
them called classified ads so I put free
dogs ad in the
classifi and uh we moved out of that
property uh four months later and moved
into an apartment that cost half as
much and uh cut her cut her rent and
cost in half that and that was the dog
it was all on the dogs the free dogs
that I gave away what happened with the
ne who who owned the cat oh the cat and
the that neighbor still got they're
still telling the story and the poor
jogger had prints those dogs are meaner
than snot those those uh Dalmatians are
onean dog that's why they put them on
firet truack nobody nobody mess with a
firet truck cuz they're mean I didn't
know that but um that's the only mean
dog I've ever owned but I didn't own it
long and so um I never heard that story
yeah so Jaden this is going to be you
telling the story someday yeah only
you're going to look uh as dumb as I
look or you're going to get rid of the
dog and go get an apartment son and put
your fiance in there and by the way go
Ahad and see the preacher this weekend
and get married and um get it all done
at once don't don't make your decisions
based on this it's it's not romantic to
live in a van there's nothing romantic
about it the only thing I didn't get to
ask him was I'm still I'm still got
Saturday Night Live skit ringing in my
head by the river if he L by the river
it that would that be the end of it I
would be losing it giant dog with the
giant dog Justin in Charlotte North
Carolina hey Justin what's
up hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can I
help well my wife and I we have some
debt that are trying to get in touch and
just try to get it out from under us uh
we've got some medical debt and some de
on our home and a
vehicle
okay how can I
help I guess I'm
just
wondering the best way to get out from
under it and we've also I've got some
land and we're wanting to build on it
but I'm kind of want to get some of the
stuff yeah you need to get the debt you
need to get the debt cleaned up before
we talk about that so what's the total
of the debt
it's probably around
200 200,000 probably on
what
uh 148 on a house oh okay
um all right 20 okay 20 on what a
vehicle okay and what else and I've got
18 on
a on a loan on the
house 18,000
MH and about 8,000 in medical debt
okay and are you guys uh is the medical
event behind you
now
um no uh we we still have check it's for
our son one of our sons he has we still
have checkups on him he's he's disabled
and it'll be an ongoing thing I believe
okay so you've got got that in the
um um you've got that in the budget the
ongoing what are you what's your
household income
sir uh around 60 okay all right well
what we teach folks to do is get on a
detailed tight written budget we can
help you that with help you do that with
the every dollar app you and your wife
sit down together give every dollar of
this month's income an assignment food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities and then let's start paying
down debt first goal is baby step one
setting aside $1,000 as a starter
emergency fund second goal is list your
debts smallest to largest pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one you have $52,000 in debt you make
$60,000 a year if you paid off 26,000 a
year that's about 2,000 a month that's
very hard to do on 60,000 uh you'd be
done in two
years yeah or if sell the car you'll be
done in one
year yeah I
I've thought about selling the car my
wife is not for it yeah she's not for it
cuz um but but if you're going to build
on this land anytime in the next 5 years
you're going to sell the car and you're
going to start living on less than you
make you guys are not big overspenders
you don't make a ton of money but you
just don't have a game plan it's not
very dialed in you could take the amount
of money you've got and dial it in and
be a whole lot better off but you got to
start making some decisions rather than
just buying stuff randomly so hang on
I'm going to put you into Financial
Peace University you and your wife go
into that class and you and your wife
use the every dooll budget together and
start making your decisions going
forward and you'll be just fine soon
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com to today to learn
[Music]
more
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
thanks for joining us hey the the Ramsey
Show annual listener survey is live we
want to know your favorite parts of the
show what you like what you don't what
you want to hear more of and uh whatever
it is we want to hear from you two ways
you can participate text the word survey
233 789 or visit ramsy solutions.com
survey if you take the survey you'll be
signed up to win possibly a
$500 gift card dad come man we're paying
people serious money to answer your
questions but or somebody some serious
money 500 bucks that's sweet not
everybody but one person that's still my
goodness gracious well thank you for
your help I of you we're we're thankful
to you obviously we're really thankful
Rachel's in Independence Kansas hi
Rachel how are
you good how are you better than I
deserve what's
up hello I was wanting um a little bit
of advice if you could about um I um my
ex fiance and I broke up about a few
months ago and we have over the course
of the last five years wacked up some
debts and that's what we have um both of
our names in and I've been advised um um
by family members like oh the only way
for me to start fresh and um maybe get
get our names off of each other's stuff
is they go bankrupt and I just kind of
wanted a an outside um perspective or
outside um piece of advice rather than
just going off of like the lawyer
perspective yeah asking a bankruptcy
lawyer if you're bankrupts like asking a
dog if it's
hungry yeah
yeah how old are you
Rachel I am 29 okay how long y'all been
broke
up um it's been about two
months after five years
huh yeah wow
okay
um so how many different items are you
attached to each other
on I it looks like only about
fiveish fiveish okay what are the
fiveish
items um a house two
cars and then at least two if not three
loans I'm trying to find out if there's
another one that's and both of our names
are just
mine okay all right no credit
cards um I have credit cards but I don't
believe both of our names are on the
credit cards okay any checking
accounts yes I have with both names oh
no we didn't do that oh no of course
not okay uh but both your names are on
the cars and on the loans on the house
deed and on the
loan yes okay what's the house
worth um that's a good question um the
lawyer asked or says you should look on
Zillow um thought that there wasn't
going to be any equity in the house um
but from what Zillow says it's worth 130
and we have 90 on it but we just
refinance I don't know how accurate that
is okay and you signed all of that okay
sign all it yeah and what do you
make um I just got a new job um so I was
making about about 60 is 65 a year now
with a new job I will be making like
around 80 85 okay all right and what do
you owe on the
cars each car which which each car and
what are they
worth um see the one is worth 40 well we
got the loan for 42,000 I think we owe
about 30 something left on the truck and
then another
car it's around 20,000 and I believe we
still owe around that okay and which one
are you
driving um the car okay all right
um okay and uh I'm assuming you have
discussed this with him after the
breakup what's that sound what's that
sounding
like yeah we um seem to We buied Up
expenses um he got since he and the boys
um I want you know I didn't want them to
move out of the house I decided to move
out I'm sorry the
boys he has um boys from a previous
marriage oh his
sons yeah okay all right and they're in
the
house yeah okay all right well uh what I
would tell you to do um if you were my
daughter um is to go uh hopefully with
someone uh in your family just to sit
there for moral support and not say
anything sit down and meet with him in
person and say um this is an ugly mess
and neither one of our Lives go forward
easily with this mess unless we together
figure out some way to undo the mess
here's my proposal to undo the mess okay
uh you refinance the house and get the
mortgage off of my name and I will deed
it to you
you get the truck out out of my name
either by selling it or by refinancing
it I will do the same with the car that
I'm driving I will either sell it or I
will refinance it and get your name off
of it that will leave only $8,000 that
the two of us have to pay off together
and I'm going to aggressively pay that
off um probably uh in the next few
months okay because it if you don't do
that it's all going to land in his lap
and you will have filed bankruptcy for
no
reason because you're not bankrupt you
just have a partnership
disillusionment another route you can go
technically speaking but it's not very
practical is if he refuses to do what I
just asked him to do um you can sue him
for the disillusionment of a partnership
what you have technically and you'd have
to ask an a different attorney not a
bankruptcy attorney about this is my
opinion is you have a general
partnership without any partnership
documents or agreements the two of you
as two individuals that were not married
went and bought a bunch of crap
together and um now that partnership has
to be undone and you're asking the court
to force him to do what I just asked him
to do that'll cost you about
$10,000 probably if you're lucky I
wouldn't do with that I would I might
sue him just to get him to make him do
it and then the suit gets dropped
hopefully you don't have to take it all
the way to court though um
but uh filing bankruptcy on this uh you
know it's kind of like taking poison and
hoping he
dies you're killing you when you file
bankruptcy and he gets all the debt he's
going to be left with the car the
truck and the house and the $8,000 debt
that's what he's going to be left
with all of that gets dumped on him when
you're no longer on it because of
bankruptcy but you're and you're free
but you now have filed
bankruptcy um which is like dropping an
atom bomb on a pissant in this situation
it's a little bit
Overkill a lot Overkill is what I'm
trying to say so I I think the two of
you ought to try to sit down and work
this out like two mature adults I have a
feeling that's probably not possible
though what do you think
we have sat down and talked um so both
of our just over the last few years our
credit has tanked really bad so we have
talked about doing this in the future so
how about selling all three of these
things then sell the house the truck and
the
car everything gets
sld well I mean we they wouldn't have a
place to live and oh darling there's all
kinds of rental properties right there
around Independence freaking
Kansas and you get get you a hoop and
you're not bankrupt and you got out of
this mess yeah folks ladies and
gentlemen when I tell you people
shacking up not to do
this Rachel is a case study on why not
to do this don't buy a house with people
you're not married to don't act like
you're married to people you're not
married to don't set up life with people
you're not married to you get screwed in
the process metaphorically this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks Dr John delone here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become healthy habits
like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with a daily practice of meditation and
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's 3 months free to prioritize your
mental health and be intentional about
finding peace through calming music
prayers meditation and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition if
you don't have a faith tradition this is
a great place to learn more about it
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember H is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to halo.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
[Music]
5225 Ken for a u old-fashioned dinosaur
like myself it was shocking to me about
a decade ago when I read the statistic
that actually more couples in America
today uh live together that are not
married than are married uh there are
more people quote unquote shacking up uh
than ever before and so the problem of
our last caller comes up um it it it's
exasperated it gets it gets really
really bad in those situations so the
thing is that
um it can come off as some kind of
oldfashioned moralistic thing which is
fine I'm an oldfashioned moralist in a
lot of ways I'm happy to go with that
I'm the anti uh to the I'm I'm that side
of the coin if you will and I'm
comfortable in my own skin on that but
that's not my my motivation my
motivation is what's good for you we
love you we want you to
win and what's good for you is to not
own a house with somebody you're not
married to because then you move out and
you can't get it off your name and then
you get married to somebody else and
have a beautiful life except you can't
get a house cuz you already got a house
in your name and you're messed up and
you're stuck and the person's being
unreasonable that is the very reason you
broke up in the first place in the past
and C certainly cars and buying things
for people and paying debt for people
that you're not married to and always
Under The Heading of This Is Love well
this is not love this is stupidity
that's right that's right because what
happens
is things do go sour and now all of a
sudden what should just be a painful
moment now becomes a painful season and
that's the problem is trying to you know
extrapolate all of this stuff and pull
all of it out and fix it and this could
get really ugly for people pretty
quickly cuz then now you don't have you
don't even have the the marriage
situation to have a judge speak into it
gets really tricky and I think that's
what people Miss oh it's going to work
out it's going to work out he loves me
he loves me well he may love you but
that doesn't mean it's going to work out
and you're setting yourself up for a lot
of trouble yeah it it just um and and
here's the other thing okay the data the
actual statistical evidence is there and
in the financial world or the soci or
social economics World um it's called
the marriage Advantage yes that even and
I'm not you know not mad at you if
you're married or you're single or
whatever none of that matters it's just
a data issue okay the data is that a
young man who gets married 20 years
later has a higher income than a young
man who doesn't get married some it's a
data Advantage it's an advantage in the
data a young man young woman that gets
married uh 20 at 25 25 years later has a
much higher net worth they have a higher
net worth they have a higher income um
on average that's the that's the actual
data that's out there and part of it is
the setback that occurs if you get
yourself tangled up like poor Rachel's
tangled up there um and uh you know cuz
what this is going to end up now she's
now gone from a $50,000 to an $80,000
income gotten rid of said boyfriend SL
fiance by the way a fiance without a
date is a glorified boyfriend you got to
set the freaking date yeah okay when are
we getting married in two freaking years
painter get off the ladder seriously
okay this is not a fiance this is a
we're playing house and trying to make
it look a little bit better to our more
moralistic friends uh well he's my
fiance well that matters not at all
obviously cuz now here you sit with two
car payments a house payment and you
only got one of the cars hell
so this is how this ends up happening uh
you you really get yourself into a mess
and the the data is out there on the
poverty cycle as well that's associated
with this so uh professor professor I'm
reading now from some of my notes Bill
galston who was on President Clinton's
domestic policy adviser um said they did
a study showing the things you only have
to do three things to avoid living in
poverty graduate from high school marry
before having a child and have that
child after age 20 if you do those three
things only 8% of the people who do so
will be at the poverty level if you do
not do those things
79% who fail to do all three will be at
the poverty level wow that's a huge
indicator M now those these are not hard
things graduate from high school don't
get married or don't have a baby before
getting married and have your first baby
after age
20 and you have an 8% chance of being in
poverty if you don't do those three
things you have a 79% chance of being in
poverty well the rich get richer and the
poor get poorer
nope the people who do rich people's
stuff get richer and the people who do
poor people's stuff get poorer it's the
way we live our lives that causes us to
reap the things in our lives I've done a
lot of stupid things in my life and
they've cost me money every time only 4%
of homes with a married mother and
father are on food
stamps only
4% 21% of those
cohabitating government for shacking up
and 28% of single mothers are on food
stamps only 4% with a married father and
mother in the home 78% of married people
own their own home 41% of shacking up
people own their own
home H home ownership by the way is one
of the key elements in wealth building
to move you from lower middle class
lower class to upper middle class or
upper class Financial stata in
socioeconomic
measures this is data people this is
data this is the result of these moral
decisions a major 2014 report from the
American Enterprise Institute for family
studies at the University of Virginia
reports that family income is 73% higher
for married women than unmarried
women
H I can help you with part of the reason
can you I instantly I can come to the
conclusion I don't I'm I'm reading into
the research yeah okay I'm I'm
commenting on the data I've got one if
you don't have to work you can demand
more money cuz you can walk out and say
take this job and shove it that's right
and so if you you know if you got two of
you working I'll guarantee you the
husband's making more money too cuz his
wife's bringing in money the two of them
are making money he's going have to put
up a crap off of some toxic situation
and somebody won't give him a raise
he'll go someplace that go got upward
Mobility she can do the same thing she's
not going to get mistreated in the
marketplace married men benefit from an
average annual economic marriage premium
of
$15,900 a year more income on average
than their unmarried
counterparts this is
data now where did we lose this data in
the decision that half of you more than
half of you are
cohabitating rather than being married
and all it does is require a trip to the
preacher or the courthouse it's not
rocket surgery it's not hard to figure
out and the advantages are all over the
place the legal advantages the
relational advantages the
economic advantages I've just outlined
for the past 10 minutes y a and oh we
can say the spiritual advantages too
okay they're there as well um because
God loves you and he has a plan for your
life and it is not to bring you
harm it's to give you hope and he says
Hey kid this is the best way to live
your life and then the data backs it up
who knew well you know there's a theme
going on I think what we see in the data
is that the word commitment when we live
it out commit
makes a difference commitment requires
you to be selfless not selfish and the
antidote uh to all of this convenience
living because this is all about
convenience the other side of the
commitment is convenience well we're
going to live together because we can
because we're we're fiance we're going
to just it's all about convenience but
the data shows that when marriage is
about commitment it's the Bedrock of the
whole thing it's a covenant it's a
commitment uh and so with commitment
comes selfless Behavior
the selfless Behavior leads to more
money more money leads to momentum and
so all in the data there I'm seeing a
struggle Dave between two words
commitment versus convenience we we live
in a convenience driven Society so I
haven't given a whole bunch of you in
social media a reason to hate on me or
to unfollow me in a while so that's what
this segment was for it's to help you
have a reason to go away some of you
wanted a reason to go away I just gave
you one that's what I'm here for I'm
here to help you're out of da we love
you you Puritan we love you we love you
and we love you as you leave bye-bye
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality host of
the Ken Coleman show and author of the
number one best-selling book paycheck to
purpose is my co-host today open phones
at8
[Music]
825-5222 th000 short of paying off my
house wow where to
go thank you I have that money sitting
in a online savings account earning
about
4.5% and my mortgage is
4% um so it's pretty much close to the
to the interest that I'm paying however
I am a single mom so I'm very um
disciplined at saving this money and
it's kind of like a buffer for me
whereas I know I'm not going to touch it
I also have um an emergency fund and I'm
completely debt free how much is in your
emergency
fund um about 8,000 what do you
make I make about 73 okay and how much
is in how much is in the uh payoff the
house
account um about 70 and I have money in
a 401k that I'm not going to touch right
you're not and um not if I can stop you
and and all right and so you have 70,000
in savings plus 8,000 in savings plus a
401k and that's
it yes and how much do you owe on your
home I owe about 89 um maybe the payoff
is like 90
okay one more time what' you say you
make um well I was making 65 I'm going
to be making about 703 I'm taking a
promotion oh good for you okay thank you
okay um how old are your
kiddos I'm sorry how old are your
children they are both over the age of
18 oh okay so you're a single mom but
not one that has to pay for people's
food correct that's the youngest one
just turned 18 okay or not much of the
food anyway all right okay there
um all right so here here's what I know
how old are you I'm 48 okay when you're
68 what's going to make you the
wealthiest that's the way I answer the
question which of these moves helps you
become the wealthiest 20 years from
today okay well from listening to you I
know about all the millionaires that
you've studied they they pay off their
house um they don't you know take that
money and invested I am still also um
for the last year I've been paying
double on my principal and um you're
you're a Frugal
person yeah they call me Frugal Fanny
and you're a self and you're a self and
you're self-disciplined as well and part
of that comes from just the fact that as
a single mom when the kiddos were little
you probably live through some times
that were
terrifying absolutely and that makes you
forever Frugal that was your Great
Depression like my grandpa was in the
Great Depression it terrified him so he
pulled Nails out straightened them and
put them in a coffee can the rest of his
life you know what I'm talking about
right that's you that's you but you're
just because you're a single mom I have
that same thing because I went bankrupt
when I was 28 we lost everything
terrified my wife and she never she
still our refrigerator to this day is so
freaking full of leftovers it choke a
horse you know and it's has nothing to
do with anything because the F so good
and it shouldn't go to waste look we're
not broke anymore all right but anyway
we all have these scars and they
manifest themselves in our lives these
ways so very interesting see here I am
complaining on the radio but anyway the
um uh uh so what would I do in your sh I
don't think your emergency fund is large
enough okay I think I want to
move 7,000 that had been on my emergency
funds by the way what now that had spend
all of my emergency funds I just SP oh
you just got lumped together I know but
I'm you said you had 8,000 in your F so
I'm going to move at least seven over
there I think I'm going to move 12 over
there cuz I'm cuz I I you know there's a
part of you that's terrified sometimes
so I want you to have
20,000 okay okay so 20,000 and that
means we don't have 70 it means we've
got 58 and we owe 80 something
right correct so how quick can you knock
down 30 if we throw that 58 at the
mortgage well ideally I I wanted to have
the home I've I've been in there 10
years I wanted it paid off before 15 I
um started doing triple toward the
princi me if you how quickly can you pay
off the 30,000 remaining balance if we
throw 58 at it today probably in less
than a year I that'd be pretty tight
you're sure you are FAL Fanny okay I'm
with you I am I'm with you all right so
why wouldn't we do that sit with 20 in
the emergency fund throw the rest of it
at it and knock the rest out in 12
months so one year from today we're
going to celebrate Halloween with a paid
for
house H feel scary because I'll tell you
I the momentum of looking at that money
and knowing that I just won't touch it
is is you know the momentum of looking
towards one year from today is and being
100% free for the rest of your
life right you got to do this
girl
you got to do it it's going to work it's
going to work okay we're not leaving you
broke you got 20 grand and you're not
going to touch it and you you know and
sitting there with no savings it scares
you a little bit right that's what
you're
saying is that is that fear not going to
motivate you to pay this house off even
faster say that again is the if we use
this money and you only have 20,000 in
the emergency fund and that makes you a
little bit scared
right correct does that fear that little
bit scared not motivate you even more
than your normal Frugal self to get the
house paid off
fast I don't know because I have
momentum right now I think you have I
think it's gonna I think it's G to raise
the probability that the house is paid
off because that fear is going to drive
you a little bit more in a healthy way
if I thought it was going to paralyze
you or terrify you I wouldn't do it or
traumatize you I wouldn't do it but I
think it's a healthy fear like get out
of the road you're going to get hit by a
car fear that's a good fear
and I I'm if I'm you that's what I'm
doing you do whatever you want to do you
call me yeah I I want to suggest
something I would S I would suggest that
you just get out a a pen and paper and
begin to sketch out what you think the
worst case scenarios are why the 70
matters 70 matters so much 58 now cuz I
moved 128 and I would just play with
this because I think what's going on is
is I think she might find that huh
20,000 makes me feel very good I like
days plan she might go you know what
this could happen this could happen this
Happ it's about
okay fine yeah we're fine with that we
do 48 yeah but I think that's the take
15 months yeah I don't think she's
thought through the tangible fears and
how much money she'd need to get back up
on her feet cuz that's what we mean by
emergency it's got to be a full-blown
dumpster Fire by which we have to touch
the emergency fund and she said multiple
times I'd never touch it I'd never touch
it even when there's an emergency she
doesn't touch it I'd like her to do that
exercise I think she'd feel better about
it yeah write it out by hand don't tou
it write it with a pencil this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netw Suite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
too join the more than 34,000 customers
who trust netw Suite to help make them
smarter and make better decisions and
level up their operations to learn more
get a free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
/
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
my co-host today our question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need to make
repairs schedule routine maintenance or
get local help for Home Improvement
projects go to neighborly decom Ramsey
your source to find and schedule
reliable home service providers in your
area today's question comes from Bethany
in Arizona I have a question about my
current employment I've been in
healthcare for 29 years and have worked
my way from staff X-ray tech to director
of radiology along the way I have
completed an associates degree in
Radiology a bachelor's in Radiology
management and I'm currently working on
my MBA in operations and supply chain
I've been struggling with my current
role and took Ken Coleman's career
assessment which show that I am
ultimately in the wrong role in the
wrong place I'm being offered to travel
technologist uh technologist position
rather that doubles my income but of
course that is a step backwards in
position travel medical personnel do not
have permanent positions and my husband
currently has a medical issue that will
prevent him to work for the foreseeable
future am I committing career
suicide um no I don't think it's that
dramatic I think you have options
there's a lot going on here in this
question Bethany
um so I if you believe that that our
assessment helped you realize you're
doing the wrong thing Radiology in the
wrong place that speaks to culture the
company itself or maybe the opportunity
within the organization meaning you
don't have a ladder um then I don't mind
the travel technologist position because
it doubles your income and I don't see
that as going backwards I understand
from a status standpoint in radiology
and you've been in this certain field
for it looks like 29 years so in this
case I actually would consider I'm not
not telling you to do it but I'd
consider it for two reasons number one
we're going to double our income and
doubling our income gives us options
More Money More margin gives me and you
options I like that secondly I think
it's a nice Bridge uh for a season
you're traveling you're stacking up the
money your husband's got some long-term
health issues so the more money more
freedom seems to be in line with that
health issue as well and what I would be
doing is if I know I'm doing the wrong
thing in the wrong place I'm taking this
season where I'm traveling getting paid
very very well to figure out what is my
next move and so from that standpoint I
unequivocally uh disagree that you would
be committing career suicide in fact
this type of change Dave that has the
benefit of more money and still keeping
stability as she transitions I actually
think it's a good move mentally not just
financially so Ken I'm um such a
planner if I saw this move as a way to
get me to where I really ultimately want
to be mhm which is in other words I'm
going to take some I'm ultimately not
going to be in Radiology it sounds like
right that's right I'm ultimately going
to be maybe uh she's working on Ops and
supply chain feels there a direction
she's moving into Logistics okay or
whatever uh but let's say Okay 5 years
from today I want to land in a new
oncore take a bow after the First Act
come out do the second act career an
encore career that is solid and it's not
going to be travel this is not a
permanent decision Radiology though is
not that location if you're going back
to Radiology it could hurt you
absolutely would but it doesn't sound
like we're saying that it sounds like
we're going in a different direction but
the more you know that this is a
stepping stone to the new place the more
you know this is not career suicide
correct yeah not at all because this is
a nice transition you know because you
it's not like you it's not like you went
backwards or you were unemployed for a
certain amount of time there's no stain
by making this move but I think the
clarity the clear the the HD High defin
detail of the future place to land drawn
out I know exactly what I've got to do
to get there and for two years I'm going
to do travel and then I'm going to land
there y the more you've got that
clarified in your mind the less
terrifying this move is that's exactly
right so if that's vague then there
there's a lot of anxiety with it's a
bridge to nowhere there we go and so in
this case the bridge that I'm talking
about is all right I'm finishing up my
MBA I've got to make some connections in
this this world of supply chain or
operations and I'm not enjoying where I
am I'm stuck let me tell you what I know
Dave about just humans in general if
we're
unhappy it's very hard to be clear it
just is you're focusing all these
negative emotions it's hard to have
great perspective if you know you were
in the wrong role in the wrong place and
you have an opportunity to get out of
the wrong role in the wrong place I
think the Fresh Start gives me fresh
perspective my emotions are better I'm
thinking clearly I'm feeling confidently
and that's how we go all right what is
my next PATH and I think that if she
knows that she wants to move to your
point into another certain direction we
know we're going to go here uh then I
love this move if she needs to uh spend
more time getting qualified it feels
like she's got to get qualified and
connected here stage two and three I've
got seven stages we unpack and paycheck
to purpose getting clear is stage one
that's that where do I want to be stage
two is I got to get qualified while I'm
getting qualified I'm getting connected
so that I can get started and this is an
a potential Bridge it's hard to say
without having on the phone but this is
not suicide no it's not suicide
particularly it's less and less and less
suicide when the the clear other end of
the bridge is resting on something other
than Radiology correct yeah that makes
sense okay here's the cool and I don't
know she said her husband has a medical
issue preventing him to work for the
foreseeable future I wonder if he can
travel if he could go with her and you
guys go stack some cash this could just
be uh you know this is a a midlife
honeymoon this is a a a an adventure a
2-year Adventure we're going to this is
better than backpacking Europe when
you're 19 I mean this is going to be fun
y'all go see the world and hang out and
and stack some cash and then land the
bridge and come back and both of you get
back in gear again agree and even more
so because he's not going to be working
the additional income really gives us
less stress on the finances too again
hard to think clearly when you're
dealing with the fog of frustration or
the fog of debt well it's turning loose
of 29 years of investment into something
by say and grieving it saying I'm not
going back there that's right that's
that's that's what makes you think it's
suicide I might go back I might need to
go back I need to go back you don't need
to go back yeah you don't need to go
back there you're going to stack cash
and you're going to land on the other
side of the bridge over in logistics or
somewhere else that you clearly outline
that's very cool good advice Ken Patty's
in Omaha Nebraska hi Patty welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi Dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's
up uh well the the question I have is
I'm buying another house um and I have
some money in a Roth and I want I but I
do have a HELOC that I've gotten ready
I'm selling my house it was going to be
that hel like was going to just be a
bridge load but now with the market
slowing down I'm a little worried about
that so I do have
$1,000 in my Roth I've always never
wanted to touch that but I think maybe I
should just use the Roth money rather
than HELOC money and I wanted your
opinion on that how old are
you 69 how much in your total Nest
Egg but I just got married in July and
um together we're doing pretty good he
sold his house got 260 for that so we've
got that going towards the new house so
we got um that money towards that and
then my house is worth another 250 if we
can get it sold but like I said the
market is slowing down and on top of
that you know I've got we've got a good
income we make we got about 30,000 in
savings on top of that you don't have
any other Nest Egg other than this
Roth um I mean I have my my retirement
fund that I get off and there Nest Egg
money
Investments uh other you don't have any
you have $30,000 to your name after you
buy this
house um well I I don't think I mean I
think we have some Investments we have
some stocks how much and then of course
uh well let me see he's got about 20,000
in stocks
but so you're not counting my mutual
fund my retirement fund that I get that
I mean there's 600,000 in that that's Oh
I thought you I thought you were talking
about you're getting a retirement
pension you're saying you have a you're
saying you have a 401k or 403b with
600,000 in it yeah oh now that makes a
difference okay that's a lot of money
that's good okay I feel a lot better now
that's yes use you yes use your Roth
don't don't borrow
money okay so if I use my Roth now what
they have said to me is I can use it and
I can turn it back in if I give it back
in 60 days yeah if you give it back in
60 days but if you're going to do that
just sell the house I mean I'd delay the
closing if you can um but yeah versus
taking out a heck I'm taking the Roth
I'm going to use the Roth yeah even if
you just use it and it's just gone I
mean it's not gone cuz you're going to
get it back out of the house when you
sell it but um yeah your net worth
didn't change you didn't spend it wow
this this is the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can can completely change
your space and add value to your home
we've recommended blinds.com for over a
decade so you know you can trust them
from blinds drapes and shutters to
motorized Shades they make it easy and
affordable to upgrade your entire home
and their team is ready to help with
everything from design consultation to
measuring and installation plus there
are never any misleading quotes or
hidden fees everything's back by their
100% satisfaction guarantee and shipping
is always free Cy blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open pH atle
88255 225 Ashley's in Greenville South
Carolina hi Ashley welcome to the ramsy
show hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's
up all right so my my question is a
business related one um last not this
past September but the year before I
purchased a bakery that was eight years
old it was a mom and pop Bakery for
about
$105,000 um it was really small over the
year we improved it um we we did some
Renovations on our own dollar we didn't
um pay for them um and unfortunately
it's not been it's not been successful
and I'm having to close it um I'm
sorry that's okay it's it is what it is
um and my question is um originally my
landlord I have five more years left on
the lease my landlord said that's fine
you can I'll let you out of it um and
that was great however um I he called
last last week and asked me how things
were going how things were moving out
and I mentioned that I was moving some
of the equipment out um he was under the
assumption that the equipment that was
built around um the space that was built
around the equipment he owned um however
the couple that I purchased the bakery
from actually sold it to me I have
purchased documents for it um and he is
holding my equipment hostage by not
letting me out of the lease unless I
leave the equipment um I am I have
considered I've looked up um Chapter 7
bankruptcy because that would give me 60
days to assume or reject the lease of
which I would reject the lease and then
my assets including the equipment would
be sold to pay off my debts however I do
not have any debt for the business it's
an LLC and I decided to get out of the
business before I went into debt who did
you sign the lease
personally I did yes okay the lease is
not in the llc's name it's in your name
so it is it is in the llc's name yes oh
did you did you guarantee it
personally yes okay doesn't matter it's
it's a personal lease you're personally
liable on the lease is what you're
telling me okay right yes okay and uh
how much is the lease payments
monthly uh they are currently 62240 they
go up by a certain percentage every year
starting in October so if so you have 5
years of $7,000 so you got somewhere
around $35,000 exposure right correct
what's the equipment
worth it's it's less than $10,000 worth
of equipment so I'm Wonder
swallow because I'm hopeful that I can
maybe start it again one day and it
would relieve some of the startup cost
down the road do you have any
money um I have about $20,000 in
personal savings in about it I sunk all
of my um all of my life savings into the
first business if you were going to buy
this equipment right now in your
situation
used what would you be willing to pay
for it if you found it on the if you
let's say you let him have it and the
next day you walked into a garage sale
and you found this same piece of
equipment sitting in someone's basement
what would you buy it for or would you
buy it tomorrow would you wait till
later um I that's a really great great
question question um the one piece of
equipment that's really I'm hanging on
to is um the oven because it's an old
oven and the old ones are the best
because they don't and you found it in
someone's basement tomorrow at a garage
sale what would you pay for
it I would pay probably upwards of
$1,000 for it
$1,000 correct okay all right so
um I think you can sit number one the
first thing you need to do is with this
l you need to sit down in
person yes we are we're meeting on
Wednesday good good because you're an
honorable person I think he's not a
dishonorable person as a matter of fact
he's got a lot of Mercy he's just
letting you out of
$35,000 he's already got someone lined
up that he will he's letting you out of
$35,000 that's not a bad I mean it's not
a bad guy he could have held you to it
uh for $1,000 oven I mean it's not a bad
trade so at the end of the day if I have
to negotiate away the ,000 oven in order
to get out of a 5,000 $35,000 exposure
it's gone he can have the oven but I
would ask him about it and just say
listen I we honestly I think you're an
honest guy and you think I'm honest and
we're just had we just did not have
alignment on this one subject uh would
you be willing to sell me the oven
because that's the only piece I'm
particularly interested in at a you know
at at whatever it's at Salvage price
which is probably $500 or $1,000 that's
the only thing I care about and the rest
of it is I care about getting out of the
lease could we work that
out yeah it uh it still just gets me
that I've already bought the oven so I
don't want to pay him for it you're
missing the point where you got out of a
$35,000 liability that probably gets
him that the tened had just decided they
weren't going to
pay yeah but he's wanted me out of there
since I signed a
lease
because he can charge double for the
people that have already lined up for it
okay um you do what you want to do
that's what I would do I would consider
this a blessing and I would um in a
horrible situation with a
heartbreak um I'd let him keep the oven
or I'd give him a th000 or 500 bucks for
it and get the documents signed to
completely relieve you of any liability
LLC or personal further on this lease so
that he can go forward um I guess if you
want to play hard from a negotiating
standpoint you could because it sounds
like he's chomping at the bit to get you
out of there and you could just say you
know what I think I'm just going to give
you another 600 bucks and stay here a
while and make him lose his potential
tenant because you keep
paying yeah if he doesn't you know if
you if you won't let me have the oven I
think I'm just going to keep paying the
rent because I think the oven's mine
I've got a bill of sale for
it and but you know honestly I I
personally wouldn't do that I personally
would this is a horrible thing you're
going through it's an emotional thing
you're going through the failure of a
business is a a crisis of identity
anytime I close a major area that we
tried here at Ramsay it's me admitting
that I was stupid and I hate admitting
that yet sometimes I am stupid and but I
get the opportunity running a business
to admit it occasionally and um it's not
fun it's really not fun I'm sorry it
really is emotional um I wouldn't threw
this whole thing up over a grand I
promise you I wouldn't you're going to
lose that the first time you meet with
an attorney they they they charge you
$1,000 for driving past their
office just like it's a driveby fee you
know I mean it's like well I think you
made a very good point that she fails to
see obviously there's some tension there
and she feels like well he has somebody
else lined up I found him she mentioned
that so she feels like she's doing some
good but the we cannot forget the fact
that this guy is going to let her out of
$35,000 contracted commitment you can't
forget get that I and I'm could be wrong
but maybe the new tenant needs the oven
I think there's a reason this guy is not
a jerk I think he's like you know what
I'll let you out of 35 I'm going to keep
the
oven that's a pretty fair trade you know
it's a tenant Improvement and you're
walking away Scott free and so um if I
were the landlord on the other side even
if I had another tenant lined up I I
would think that's a fair deal I think
it's a very fair deal so um it's up to
you though you can do what you want to
do let me ask you this Dave you could
drag it if he's got the other tenant and
he could lose the other tenant by you
delaying him that's a way to screw with
it if you want to do it but do so at
your own Peril but I was going to ask
you because you've you've been a
landlord you are a landlord if she hacks
him off in some way or just starts
negotiating he's like wait a second I'm
letting you out of this deal and I don't
want the stinking oven and he gets he
could hold her to this contract and he
hold her the $ 35,000 he could put her
in some room she says she says that he's
got somebody want to pay double so you
know that's the the leverage back and
forth I don't know I mean to me that's
almost irrelevant though it's what what
the deal is to you yeah okay the deal is
you personally put your pen to paper and
said I will pay you
$35,000 and he says hey you brought me
another tenant I'll let you out that's
an act of
Mercy it's not a it's not a legal
requirement or a moral or an ethical
requirement um and you know if he
misunderstood and thought the tened
improvements became his as an act after
to the act of Mercy then that's
something you can discuss with him and
I'm recommending you discuss it but
wouldn't push it too hard it's ,000
bucks for 35 it's a good trade this is
the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host hey guys if you like the show we
need your
help
help click the Subscribe button and
follow subscribe to the show on YouTube
or on podcast click the follow button on
YouTube or on podcast it changes
everything if you do that in addition to
that uh click the share button or click
the or cut the link out and share share
the link um I pulled a uh a a poignant
thing off of Instagram this morning that
I stumbled into I'm not on Instagram
very often but I sent it to my wife and
said this right here this right here see
all what I do I just click the link the
share button on it and it sent it right
over there so you guys can do that it
helps us a bunch because we're not
spending 300 million a year on uh
football stadiums like s so um excuse me
um but the um the uh yeah so we don't we
don't have that option we're just uh
regular folks doing a radio show podcast
YouTube thing where we help you and
since you don't pay for this one way you
can help us is share it follow it
subscribe it thank you oh and five star
reviews are helpful too all right
Kelly's in Charlotte North Carolina hi
Kelly how are you hey Dave how are you
thanks for taking my call sure what's
up um so I was calling um I left the
healthc care field almost four years ago
um and I've been a stay-at-home mom
since then um and my husband has been
the um sole uh income provider and I
have felt the need all these years to
keep up with all my medical
credentialing paying for the licensing
and the continuing
education um but my husband feels like
it is a security blanket that I am
keeping because I really don't have a
desire to return to the medical field um
but I tell him that it is not it's a low
cost uh or not low cost but it's a good
thing to keep investing in in the event
that something were to happen to him
what is your what do you do you're an MD
a nurse what a physici assistant pa okay
what does it cost annually to maintain
it um around $400
dollars correct yeah so absolutely keep
that yeah but I want to know is he right
is he right or is he wrong is this a
security blanket that if something would
happen to him or do you have your in the
back of your mind maybe one day when I
when I done getting the kids launched
that I want to get back into it what
where where do you fall on that I would
I would I mean not I'm not going to
disagree with him that it's a security
blanket I tell him that my concern and
maybe it's because I worked in the e um
is that you know if something happens to
you and I'm not worry about you dying
I'm worrying about to living but being
disabled and in a nursing home for a
long time that's always like the
argument we have because is it both I
think it's both and I think you're smart
for saying that part but I think you're
I think you're open to maybe getting
back into it one day at least to the
point that you'd like to have it as an
option is that true or
false I would be open to an option but
just not the area of medicine that I
left okay right but you keep the way I
look at it is you you invested a lot of
time and money to become a PA you lose
it all for 400 bucks no
way okay yeah cuz it's it's a lot more
work to go back yeah yes it's a pain in
the butt you got to go sit for the
boards
again yeah yeah not a
chance I absolutely keep yeah I'm I'm
absolutely keeping it okay I kept all of
my licenses for a long time the only one
I now have is my real estate license
I've had it since
1978 uh but and we actually actually use
the real estate license it's tied into
our rly trusted program so technically I
have a need for it uh today but I
dropped all of my others uh the
Securities license insurance license all
those kinds of things uh after I got on
the radio because I didn't want any of
those Industries or Regulators telling
me what I could say so me dropping that
was giving them the middle finger so I
can tell a bunch of these insurance
people to stick it which is perfect for
me so I it was easier for me to drop it
and better for me to drop it but prior
to that I had not been in the security
or Insurance World in
years but those tests are hard insurance
is not it was a joke but the the dad gum
Securities tests like taking a CPA and
so I didn't want to sit for that thing
again and so for a 100 bucks 200 bucks I
could keep that license active even
though I was no longer in the business I
got the only reason I dropped it again
was I didn't want to be regulated by
those doofuses so um uh but the uh and
I'm not going to be selling securities
anymore obviously but the the uh that
that's the same kind of thing for me I
would keep it on that basis uh
regardless of whether it's a security
blanket regardless of whether you're
going back to work or not I wouldn't
lose all the work you did for 400
bucks okay if it was 4,000 will talk
about it is he that tight or is he just
like this is silly to be paying this I
think he's just s he thinks it's just
silly I mean he we've done spu we're on
baby step seven I mean we're doing good
and I like where he's coming from with
that but it's you know you might want to
go on the mission field and the PA would
be handy yes yeah absolutely mean this
is a yard sale you know what you do just
say you're so tight man we're on baby
step seven I'm going to do one yard sale
a year and take care of this I'm going
to sell all the clothes you don't wear
honey and pay for it That Consignment
sale 400 bucks that suit that's been
hanging in the back of your closet for S
years you've not put on darling I'm
going to sell that that's what I think
he do I'm selling his clothes he'll
never bring it up sell his clothes he'll
never bring it up again that's
true he's on baby step seven but I I
appreciate it he's like that dude does
not like to waste money great discuss
$4,000 my you might trip my trigger but
400 doesn't Eric is with us Eric's in
Oklahoma City hi Eric how are you hey
hey Dave how are you guys better than we
deserve for sure what's up perfect well
hey my wife and I we're kind of bad the
idea of a few financial decisions um
between paying off our student loans
keep saving to buy a house next year do
we invest more how much do we keep
saving and so we're really just kind of
feeling a lot of outside pressures to
different decisions and what we should
do and we're just re not really feeling
clear on our next steps and decisions
and what consequently you're not getting
really great traction on any of them
right right yeah lack of focus does that
it disperses the
energy right right and so right now
we're just kind of we have so many
options we're we're doing pretty good
financially um we don't have any debt uh
honey you have student loan debt yeah
besides their student loan debt that's
de how much student loan debt have you
got 200,000 good God Jesus
Mercy we don't have much debt we're
really doing good I've only got 200,000
that just came out of your mouth
okay okay yeah yeah yeah what's your
household income sir we are making about
130,000 a year combined what do youall
do so I am a film director uh I
specialize in uh the film space uh video
space here in Oklahoma and my wife is an
attorney and that's where the law that
the law degrees with the 200,000 yeah
yeah why does she not make any
money she makes about 105,000 a year oh
so you don't make any money okay just
just about it's my first year uh doing
this uh so we're hoping for we're seeing
some good growth so far toward the end
of this year so you guys are how old are
yall 26 I'm 30 and she's 27 okay all
right well um and you're new to this
whole Ramsey thing apparently yeah we've
we took a course through of church last
year with you guys and uh it's G we
learned a lot of kind of Financial Peace
University yes correct mhm huh okay uh
you flunked you got to go back um yeah
cuz we taught you in that a thing called
the baby steps and it said don't buy a
house until you're out of debt you
remember that one yep do remember that
and it said uh we're not investing until
we're out of debt and have an emergency
fund in place cuz we work the baby steps
baby step two is become debt free
everything but the house three is an
emergency fund four is was investing
into retirement and that gives you the
focus and the clarity that you're
looking for that was in that class and
that's what we teach and that's what
we've taught 10 million people to do and
that's why it's a proven plan to
financial Fitness y'all have a mess dude
you need to clean up your $200,000 mess
yeah just a little bit that's what I'd
be focusing on it's not a little bit you
need to quit minimizing it it's you have
a dad gum big old pile of manure right
in the middle of your living room
$200,000 do is a lot of student loan
debt so you need to work on that let's
get that cleared up and then we'll build
an emergency fund then we'll save up for
a house and then we'll start our
investing that's your order of attack
don't think you're going to do it but
that's what you should do this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people bill wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality host of the Ken Coleman show
author of the number one bestselling
book from paycheck to purpose is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
88255 225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money George is in
New York City to start off this hour hi
George how are you hey George George how
are you days better than we deserve
George how can we
help uh yeah I was curious if you could
help me with one thing so I grew up in a
situation where my family didn't have
much Financial lior room and now I'm in
a place where I can spend a bit more
than I used to be able to I live in New
York City like you said I work in
finance I'm single and as it stands i
max out my 40K each year and have fair
amount J um I I guess it's just that
every time I I think about spending
money on myself there's this
overwhelming feeling of guilt that I get
and I don't know if this is something
that's common that a lot of people feel
but uh yeah I was curious if you could
help me ration my way out of it or maybe
if you could tell me that if it's if
it's a rational feeling it's so common
that it's almost everyone in your
situation wow so it's very rational uh
is guilt the right word or uh fear are
you you feel bad towards like you hurt
someone else or
what that's a great question I think it
is more fear actually because I think
the feeling is more related to I feel
like I'm irresponsible am I being
irresponsible if I spend this yes
exactly and it's it's a feeling of like
do I do I know that like the the current
situation can last forever and if I have
spent this and then something turns like
that that would be gotcha gotcha that is
universal uh by people who move from not
having money to having money um I
certainly have experienced it I mean Ken
you and Stacy Stacy and Sharon his wife
and my wife are good friends we've all
talked about this on trips we've been
together like we're sitting in some trip
and we're like how can we believe we're
actually in this place we're sitting
here together having this meal oh my
gosh give us an example give us an
example of something because I want to
walk you through that emotion give us an
example where you felt this you wanted
to buy it or you did buy it then you had
a negative feeling afterwards or in the
process of getting it yeah um actually
so it's a pretty uh like current example
because I just came back from a trip to
Portugal and I was there for two weeks
and it was a pretty incredible trip um I
got to spend a lot of time like in you
know some of the big cities I've been
wanting to visit and also just the
outdoors but I guess did you go to
Lisbon I did go to Lisbon fabulous isn't
it did you go up to did you go up to
Duro Valley I did I did it's uh I mean
that's the home of Port boys and girls
that's about as good a port as you'll
get cuz that's the only place it's from
wow I'm thirsty I'm thirsty all of a
sudden man that's a great trip I've done
that wonderful trip did you pay cash for
it uh yeah I did how much was the
trip um Portugal's pretty cheap but the
flights were expensive I think all in I
probably spent three to $4,000 how much
money do you
make um in a year last year I made 400k
um and and how much do you have in
savings um last year was my first year
getting a paycheck like that and so I
have 140k in savings and how old are you
I'm 26 way to go George way to go what
do you do for a
living I work on Wall Street I'm so
proud of you way to go stud so one quick
question George did you earn that
trip um did you earn $400,000 yes or no
did you earn the right did you earn that
trip did you
work I I did did you steal the
money I did not do that okay that's the
point yeah you did listen you're great
financial shape and you worked hard and
you were Frugal in you didn't spend
30,000 on the trip you spent 3 to 4,000
your single 1% man listen this is I I
tell you what I think this is too
somebody making 30,000 spending 300
bucks yeah this is the family you came
from the environment I think you were
over there and you're like I can't
believe I'm here and I feel a little
guilty that I've earned this right to
get here and maybe some of my family
members didn't I mean there's some of
that too that's why you use the word
guilt is that true
that that is exactly what it was I think
like comparison comp like eating food
and and you know experiencing whatever I
was doing and thinking like oh my
parents never got to experience this but
I'm getting to do this right now and I
guess there was a feeling of like oh
should my parents be here or like should
this be like a eventually take him on a
trip one day thank him for it but you
don't have to like walk around with this
guilt that that you're standing on their
shoulders and you are and I love that
Spirit to know that your mom and dad
made sacrifices they are proud of you
they're proud that you're doing this so
let me uh let me give you to answer your
question in a macro way number one Ken
and I are saying you have permission you
did a great thing you should have done
that you should have if you had called
us we would have said take the trip okay
absolutely and there's a couple of ways
that I can make that decision in my
current life and feel no shame regret
guilt fear irresponsible vibes okay
number one there are three things you
can do with money you can invest invest
it you can enjoy it and you can give it
with generosity you should always be
doing all three things with your money
you should always have built-in systemic
generosity and random
generosity you should in other words
large
tips um is an example of wonderful
generosity okay um you you know just
walk up and pay for somebody's gas at
the gas pump randomly that's little ones
right or and big ones too you make $400
freaking th000 let's do some generosity
all right let's do some investing you've
already saved $140,000 you've only made
400 in one year that's a good savings
rate well done you're doing really good
by the way at 26 you're mature
emotionally beyond your years because
one definition of maturity is the
ability to delay pleasure immature
people don't even ask the freaking
question that you're asking okay so this
is incredible very very well done sir
proud of you so you should always enjoy
your money if you are being systemically
and randomly generous and you are
investing systematically as well then
when you choose to enjoy a percentage of
your money you can do that easily
without any negative Vibes or negative
emotions especially if you do one last
thing and I always put it to the burn
the money in the middle of the floor
test okay if I'm getting ready to do
something that feels opulent or feels
wacky compared to my childhood or feels
like something my parents would have
never been able to do or my friends
maybe can't do if I ask myself is it
okay if I do that is God going to be mad
at me for this level of enjoyment of
this money I ask myself if I take that
amount of money and put it in the middle
of the floor and light it on
fire is my life going to
change if it's enough money that my life
would change that tells me I've got to
much going into this
crap but 3,000 bucks out of 400 you
wouldn't even noticed
it you passes the burn the money in the
floor test too so that's how we know
that you're more than okay here dude if
you were over spending and acting like
you were in Congress we'd have been all
up in your game don't worry about it we
tell you we love you enough to tell you
the truth but the truth also is if you
got your generosity game going your
investing game going also have your
enjoyment game going these are the only
good things that you can do with money
and you ought to do them all this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my my
co-host Sherry is with us Sher is in
Chicago hi Sherry how are you all right
how are you thank you for taking my call
sure is it shie or Sherry Sherry Sherry
okay how can we
help all right so I I am thinking about
changing career um I can guess this will
be my third uh maybe a second uh career
change um and I'm just kind of like a
little bit freaking out because this is
more of a a change where I'm getting a
paycheck paycheck every other week that
kind of a deal so and currently am
working as a procurement in in that in
the industry and um I'm thinking about
going into like being in a real estate
like I'm a real estate agent why and the
market why um one of the thing is is
like I I want to be my own boss I want
to go into you know you know make my own
hours you know if I put that much effort
into it then that's what I'm going to
get I just don't want to
be you know chasing after the carrot you
know you don't want a ceiling on your
income and you want to be in
control most likely yeah definitely
that's what I'm going what do you make
what do you make as a procurement
professional um currently I make uh 75
right now
75 okay 75,000 do you have any debt
what's your other financial situation
look like um still I know I am married
and my husband actually is you know he's
like a de analist and he makes up about
120 okay and we don't have any debt um
we actually paid all those off like
years ago we actually make make sure
actually I made sure that you know those
debts were just gone I mean like we
don't have any car payments other than a
mortgage like we do have some credit
cards here and there but it's not that
much it's if we just pay it off every
month you know that kind of thing um all
right so let's let's look at this real
estate have you spent time with a
realtor to where you know the ins and
outs the Good The Bad how long it took
him to get going how much of a snapshot
do you have of a realistic launch into
this
industry so that's the thing so I
started taking a course and I have
talked to like one or two people
regarding it and I have you know gotten
some like goods and bads and some people
say they really love it other people say
they really hated it all right so hold
on the people who said they loved it
were they successful real estate
professionals um yeah they were actually
successful what about the people that
hated it were they successful they they
were not successful so they they totally
hated different opinion kind right well
but there there's a reason I'm pressing
you on this there's a reason why that is
and you've got to understand uh of the
stuff that you heard that was well I
loved it did that resonate with you of
the stuff that they said they hated it
did that resonate with you I mean you
have to understand am I wired for this a
lot of people in America in fact Dave uh
I I saw some data recently 70% of
Americans want to be self-employed but
only 7% % are now there's a gap there
for a reason that's a massive Gap and
the Gap is here's what here's what that
data tells me Sherry and this is why I'm
pressing you for a moment people want
the freedom the 70% want the freedom but
only 7% are willing to do what it takes
to get said freedom and many times you
work harder for yourself in fact most
people would tell you work wor boss
you'll ever have yeah exactly so I want
to make sure that you have looked into
this the good the bad the ugly and is it
something that that you deeply enjoy or
is it just an Avenue towards this
Freedom that I want that quite frankly
we all R want but most people aren't
willing to do what it takes to get this
Freedom so let me help you a second I
grew up in the residential real estate
business Mom and Daddy owned a company I
got my license when I turned 18 I sold
real estate all the way through college
I sold for a couple years after that
residential real estate agents work by
definition
when other people aren't
working so be ready to work nights and
weekends or plan or don't plan to sell
any houses that's
right yeah no that part I understand
completely okay and be be ready and and
know that you're going to work really
really hard and spend a lot of time on
the first few deals and a lot of them
are going to blow up because you don't
know what you're doing yet you don't put
them together right and so it's gonna be
really freaking frustrating the first 6
months is hell it's boot camp if you can
get through the first 6 months and do
two or three transactions you might make
it in the second six months but you're
going to be working 60 to 80 hours a
week to get this up off get this
airplane off the
ground right this is not for the faint I
I want to ride around and show houses
three hours a week and make $100,000 a
year bull crap this doesn't happen y I
mean this is the only industry that
people put Glamour Shots on their
business cards
and and and 90% of the people leave the
business when the market slows down like
this so it is a great time to get into
the real estate business because you
don't have a lot of competition right
now it's also a hard time to get in the
business because there's not a lot of
property moving right now the turnover
is not nearly like it was a few years
ago it's harder to sell a house and
there's not as many houses for sale and
so uh both both are happen when the
economy slows down and bomic and so
that's what you're sitting in the middle
of by this time next year it might be
different I hope it is for God's sakes I
hope it is but um but in the meantime
you've got a real harsh environment you
are walking into um and can it be done
sure it can be done I made a living in
1983 interest rates were
177% and I sold houses I don't know how
in the crap that happened but I was just
too dumb to not to stop and so I sold
houses but I worked like a maniac and I
was only 23 years old
so I was dumber than a rock but you can
do it I'm not going to tell you to not
do it I'm just telling you there's a lot
of hours a lot of
frustration a lot of
drama cuz people are mean when they're
moving yeah there's one thing that I
heard Sherry and I want you to I'm GNA
give it back to you because I know you
got a question but one thing I heard in
your voice was you said and what you
said you said I want to be able to put
the effort in and control it's going to
take you a while to build a pipeline and
a reputation up to where you can you can
can downshift and control it like that
do do you understand what we're saying
on that no I completely understand what
you're saying it's just that um I right
now I'm in a point in my life I mean
like I still have 20 more years that
before I could actually retire and I
actually went through like hell going
through the cancer survival you know you
know it took me it took me two and a
half years just to recover from it and
it's still like I'm having some side
effect effects that I still have to
recover from oh and yeah me too but it's
not but things are looking good and you
know I want you can beat you can beat
that you can you can win the real estate
game yeah before before I was so afraid
to just like you know do like be my own
you know go through my own business you
know like do something on my own but
like you know after having a face- t-
face conversation with death kind of
changes the perspective a little bit you
know what I mean so yeah well
practically speaking can you financially
do it if it takes you six years to get
on six months excuse me six months to
get on your feet I know SC scared her to
death uh can you guys do that
financially live on your husband's
income for six months cuz you got 75,000
going
away I got 75,000 going away however we
do have about $50,000 in our Cous I
don't want you burning it yeah you need
to live on his income I'm not burning it
can you live on his inome on his income
I to live on his income then live on his
income and go do it perfect but but just
go in knowing this is going to be
hard yep and I I I am not expecting this
to be easy by any means the rule rules
of business when I'm talking to entree
leaders when I'm talking to entree
leaders that are talking about starting
their own business it takes twice as
long as you think it's going to it costs
twice as much as you think it's going to
and you're not the exception those are
the three
rules okay yeah and then another thing
is like I just heard that you know like
right now that you know there's a lot of
people in real going into real estate
agent you know being an agent and
whatnot and it's a great time to get in
because everybody else is getting
out and I've got an edge for you uh Dave
and I are really good friends with with
Brian buffini buffini and Company he's
one of the top he is the top coaching
company in the world for real estate
professionals I would highly recommend
you connect with Brian buffini buffini
and Company and use them as your coaches
to get you going because they walk you
through all this they know it's like's a
great guy and Ken's not kidding he's the
top company it's the largest coaching
company they coach more than anyone else
and they do the best job in our opinion
they're really incredible so be sure and
check him out hey I think you can do it
Sher I'm just warning you that this is
not a uh this is not Skittles rainbows
and a uh you know uh Yellow Brick Road
there's flying monkeys out there be
ready this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
I
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
8825 5225 in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Eric
and Alysa are with us hey guys how are
you doing great doing great good how are
you welcome where do you live Harrisburg
Pennsylvania oh that's fun well welcome
to Nashville how much debt have you two
paid off
$125,000 all right how long did that
take uh about four years good for you
and your range of income during that
time started at 990,000 all the way up
to 150,000 cool what do youall do for a
living I'm in sales I'm in marketing
very good how long you two been married
uh about two years oh so you started on
this before you got married yes very
good and completion after marriage I
like it what kind of debt is the
125 student loans is most of it and then
cars uh credit cards that's pretty much
it okay okay who had the most
me you kind of owned that the way you
brought it up yeah yeah all right was it
all you no okay all right good I'm
feeling better now all right so 125,000
of normal yeah yeah and then you two
meet and start working towards getting
out of debt then get married two years
ago and complete tell us the story how'd
you get connected to Ramsey and how' you
decide as a young couple you were going
to do this yeah we were living kind of
like just going went along and uh it
just it felt like we were we had adult
responsibilities but we were still
living in a lot of ways like children uh
who didn't like the word no and that was
really stressful so uh I actually
listened to entree leadership first and
then um I I listened to that for a while
and then I was like I'm going to check
out Ramy show see what it's all about
and then um it just felt like what we
were missing the discipline that we were
missing um and later that night I uh had
him listen into it and I was worried
that he was going to think it was like
too extreme or um but he was right on
board right away and from that point we
were game on uh we cash flowed our
wedding uh one of our dogs needed like a
$5,000 surgery we were able to cash flow
that washer and dryer it's like
different things came up along the way
but um like you say Dave it it turned
into um an inconvenience rather than an
emergency and uh so it was wonderful a
great a great uh way to start our
marriage as well
way to go so Eric she says uh this weird
guy on the thing here I want you to
listen to this you had to roll your eyes
a little I mean at first I did but
honestly what we were doing wasn't
working I mean we started the journey
separately and you know when we were
dating even I I was down to my last $20
sometimes and I was like oh we should go
on a date and I was like well I better
get my credit card out and pay for that
and once she brought it to me I was like
okay this makes sense you know I'm no
more dates yeah
yeah
exactly see what you
did oh man that's fun so now what was
the last thing you paid off student loan
student loan the big one you gave old
Sally May her eviction notice oh yeah
yeah pretty cool so I this is seems
particularly relevant right now why
didn't you guys just wait to see if
Uncle Joe and his proposal was going to
come through why' you keep attacking it
we we thought about it and we for a
minute but ultimately we were like you
know we've already got this momentum
we're already going at it hard let's
just do it there's nothing's gaining
interest right now it's the best time to
be doing it and I I can tell just
because I have friends who didn't and
you know they're kicking themselves now
yes sir so
wow yeah yeah the old interest and the
payments have kicked back in and they
kick some people in the teeth in the
process it's tough out there for some
folks right now oh yeah I'm so glad
y'all are free way to go way to go thank
you uh what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is I'd say for me
personally it was having that strong
reason why um what was your why mine was
growing up you know my parents grew up
middle class uh but that meant having
helocs taking out you know credit cards
and everything and I can remember
watching my dad at the kitchen table
talking to credit card you know holders
and everything and you know I'm going to
pay that next week I'm going to you know
get to that this week or telling us not
to answer the phone cuz you know he he
knew who was calling and I knew I didn't
want to put that stress on us I mean
they gave us everything that they could
for us kids growing up but I knew I
wanted to be able to honor them by by
not doing that and being able to build
an even more bigger life for that our
kids H you know that's something that's
interesting that with the culture doing
away with the home
phone uh the family phone and the family
living room family kitchen there's no
longer there uh the kids don't get to
hear the collector calls yeah it's
true you're right it's a lot easier to
head outside or in the garage it's never
it's never a thing I mean you just look
down block that one yeah when it was
ringing off the hook at home the kids
like I got it Dad you know don't answer
it yeah that's a that I hadn't thought
of that in a long time that's an
interesting change though in the way we
do technology in our lives so um Al
Alyssa what about you what do you say
the key to getting out of dead is I
think uh it was the budget the
discipline learning that Noah the
complete sentence um we don't have to um
keep up with what everybody else is
doing we can do our own thing um and be
on our own path towards our future while
you were doing this for four years
125,000 what was the biggest money
fight I I'll take this one uh so for my
job I'm on the road a lot you know I
drive every day and during those drives
I'd like to stop at a gas station grab
you know a coffee or you know pack of
beef jerky or something but that wasn't
in the budget so anytime that would hit
the budget and we didn't talk about it
it we'd see that in the every dollar pop
up and it wasn't a beef jerky category
there was not uh-oh not even a dime
uh-oh feels like that still has a little
pain attached to it I saw that there was
a little a little ouch little scar there
little scarring it still
happens does he have a beef jerky budget
now I do now you should have now yeah
should have beef furky and coffee yeah
you got to have that that's gas station
food man you got to do it yeah that's
good I like that so yeah so you came you
came home to the Walk of Shame and said
it was a beef jerky day and she's like I
know I've already seen it mhm she knew
Fridays was usually that day so oh by
then you made it all week and then
you're well power dies on Friday yep I I
know the feeling I know this guy okay
way to go man that's awesome good good
good uh realism I appreciate that
you're 100% free you're how old 33 29
wow how's it feel the best feeling ever
I can't explain it sometimes yeah y'all
can do anything now if you can attack
this monster kill this Dragon you can
kill anything I'm so proud of you way to
go very well done well done guys who was
your biggest encouragement outside of
the two of you yeah we had uh our
friends they were they thought we were
crazy but once we told them that we
couldn't spend money on things only free
activities they were supportive come
over for game night movie night um yeah
and they were always happy to just come
hang out our house or invite us over to
their house well you keep doing that now
oh yeah yeah I mean it's fun it's better
Community than the other stuff
absolutely it's much more personal than
some loud bar where you can't hear each
other talk right it really is it's it's
you can have an actual conversation with
an actual friend yes yeah we had friends
over Friday night for dinner and it's an
oldfashioned thing to have people to
your house for dinner MH it really is
it's it's it's a gone it's a lost art I
mean it's really really well but you all
brought it back I'm proud of you hey
we've got the live and give box for you
the baby steps millionaire book that's
your next step in the process you'll be
there soon the uh Total Money Makeover
book to give away and get someone
started and a Financial Peace University
membership to either go through or give
away as well it's your live and give box
our way of saying thanks for coming to
Nashville to do your debt free scream
all the way from Harrisburg Pennsylvania
Eric and Alyssa they're Heroes they did
it they took took control of their lives
while everyone else stands around and
watches way to go you two
125,000 paid off in four years making 90
to 150 count it down let's hear a
debt-free
Scream 3 2 we're de
[Music]
[Applause]
free I love
it well
done man
absolutely
amazing good good work this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
our scripture of the Day psalm
328 I will guide you along the best
pathway for your life I will advise and
watch over
you John Rockefeller said if you want to
succeed you should strike out on New
paths rather than travel the worn Paths
of accepted
success yeah it's interesting Ken the uh
difference between the wisdom of
studying other people and finding what
we in business call Best
Practices um versus just carving your
own path and making your own way um
sometimes doing an old thing a new way
is a good is a good idea yeah well you
know it's really the heart of
Entrepreneurship they they the problem
aren't necessarily new but the solutions
to these problems are new and that's how
we see the entrepreneurial Spirit The
Innovation they are by definition
cutting their own path to find a new way
to solve a problem or create a new
solution a new desire for people and
that's the that's the name of the game
right there yeah it really is the one
that always just uh enthralls me and I
always just think it's so interesting
taking something that is so standardized
and finding a new a different take on it
in the 1920s there was not any uh Freon
there was no Refrigeration you had a box
in your house that was insulated and the
wagon or maybe a motorized vehicle but
likely a wagon delivered a large block
of ice with tongs and they set the block
of ice in the Box for you to keep your
milk your eggs your meat cool was called
an ice box that's where some people
still call their refrigerator an ice box
because their great grandmother that
right um then Along Comes Refrigeration
General Motors invented uh found the
chemist found Freon and invented what we
now call air conditioning and
refrigeration and uh the frigider was a
division of General Motors was born and
they started making refrigerated uh
boxes that go in houses called uh we
called them fridges or refrigerators or
frigidaires first brand that got brand
penetration was frigidaires so one of
the ice houses that used to deliver ice
in North Dallas was called uh was owned
by a guy nicknamed his name was Johnny
they nicknamed him Uncle Johnny was
uncle Johnny's place and he had this
huge ice house and he had figured out
that if he would store in the ice house
it was at a central location in North
Dallas a um if he would store some meat
and some eggs that people would come by
in the mornings on their way to work or
in the evenings after work and pick them
up and he C he used the ice house to
store and he had a little store going
there on the side well ice houses of
course went out of Vogue because there
was no more ice boxes because
refrigerators put them out of business
right but Uncle Johnny kept selling more
and more stuff out of his ice house and
he ended up chopping up the ice and
would bag it for
picnics and U he named his little store
after the hours he was open from 7 to
11: oh man there it is that's beautiful
isn't that a great story it's a great
story that's entrepreneur but that that
it's burn it was born out of a business
that went out of business right because
of Technology yeah and so ice is now no
longer delivered to houses has to be
chopped up and put in a bag and uh but
by the way we've been selling some eggs
and some bread here I love that and now
we sell lotto tickets but yeah and and
to bring It full circle on the ice the
greatest thing 7-Eleven has ever sold
and ever will sell is the Slurpee the
Slurpee the flavored ice drink so Uncle
John that's great you really had me
there I felt like this was the old days
har the rest of the story you really did
do a Paul Harvey right there the rest of
the story that's great yeah by the way
if you're young that's a market it's a
market disruption and we have all this
technology that is Market disrupting
everything the internet has disrupted
almost every industry in one way or
another um the grocery business is now
interrupted right um you know uh we
we've got
uh the an amazing number of people that
work here in the office that don't go to
grocery stores anymore including one of
my daughters which will not which shall
go unnamed her name sounds like Rachel
yeah and starts with a Rachel Rachel
that's how it sounds she doesn't go to
the grocery store no she has that um
automatic delivery crap and so she's um
well this is going she's truly a true
Millennial I did not know this this will
lead to some great harassment next time
I see her well that's good that's good
because we know she
Rachel harassment is always good very
interesting once it all delivered yeah
Ben is in Anchorage Alaska hi Ben how
are you hey um how's it going better
than I deserve what's up um hey I was
calling um my wife and I were basically
at um baby step four I guess uh looking
to so you're saving 15% into
retirement yep we uh went through in our
budget and we have about 17 % left over
after you know home repair funds and car
funds and all that stuff but we're debt
free um and sort of saving up post
things for Replacements and whatnot um
and then uh trying to decide what to do
with that
177% um obviously we'd like to invest
for retirement but we would also like to
start a business and um what kind of a
business do you want to
start uh she's a baker um she's been a
baker her whole life and um is looking
but she's always worked for someone else
and so she's looking to um kind of get
out on her own and and um what would she
bake uh we're actually gonna start uh
with pizzas piz is kind of the magnet
and then the and then uh artisan bread
you know you mean pizza
crust Well we'd be selling pizza oh so
you're going to the pizza restaurant
business yeah and then and then from
there the the baked she really wants to
sell baked goods and bread I like
Artisan sour dough bread um but the
pizza would be kind of the um are you
going to prepare it like at a restaurant
or is it going to be C cold and I heat
it up when I get
home uh at we're gonna we're looking to
start a food truck ultimately a food
truck okay y expensive expensive way to
start that's very
expensive yeah so we're not we don't
have enough money to start that way so
we're we're going to start um with a
small trailer that I'm going to make
with two tiny ovens
okay what does that
cost that is probably going to cost
around 10 grand okay and what do you
make um what do I make what's the
household
income uh the household income is around
uh 115 great save up 10 grand build the
trailer and start the bakery and the
trailer on the side as a side
hustle yeah um but ultimately we would
like to have up to that um uh that
larger food truck um so we we'd like to
save for that and we would do guess what
the trailer the trailer with two ovens
will pay for the food truck if you work
your butt off that's our goal yeah um
that's a side hustle that's extra income
above
115 right um I guess uh why do I not
believe
you well my the question I was going to
ask was my my company pays uh 10%
towards retirement of my gross income
per year um without me having to do
anything and so what I would like to do
is put an additional 5% towards that to
get 15 and then that's not the 15 we're
talking about the 15 we're talking about
comes out of your income and if they
match you the matching the matching is
gravy on a business on a biscuit you can
do both save up 10 grand and go build
the pizza trailer the pizza trailer will
sell fund itself you don't have to not
invest to retirement to get a food truck
the pizza trailer the two oven trailer
will buy the food truck but it may take
two years hey I didn't start this thing
with Studios and 2,000 Mi of wire and
18,000 computers or whatever it is I got
in this stupid building uh I started I
started this Radio Show in a radio
station that someone else owned and they
let me use it to do my radio show and I
went and made money and after I made
money I bought my first little computer
and two microphones and we finally got
our own little studio and it was pitiful
it was the pizza
trailer yeah which is what we're going
for I
just but now dude I'm I'm sitting in the
freaking Taj Mahal over here of
Studios MH but I didn't start there it
was 20 years
ago right you'll get there you'll get
there yeah you got to focus on proving
the business first everybody wants to
accelerate I heard the word accelerate
and scale you don't have you don't have
to you don't have to choose between
retirement and business success and by
the way Dave the acceleration takes care
of itself to your you know what I mean
it's if the pizza's good if the pizza's
good the bread's good you can't keep
people away from good pizza they just
attracted like flies man for that matter
artisan bread too my mouth's watering
right now I need to stop and get a
sandwich get him some Sour Dough Bread
James please can we get him a loaf quick
get me a give me a loaf in here right
now that puts us our the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
n
for